[Music]
you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive it's time to see what's
making the headlines with susie boniface
daily mirror economist and freddie gray
deputy editor of the spectator magazine
they'll be with us from now until just
before midnight so let's see what's on
some of those front pages for you now
the telegraph says the government's
scientific advisors have said a fourth
coronavirus vaccine dose will not be
necessary
there's been a rush by the double jabbed
to book holidays abroad that's on the
front of the mirror
the chancellor is being urged to revisit
the suspension of the triple lock in
order to help vulnerable pensioners
that's according to the financial times
the express reckons we're collectively
sitting on a savings pot of 1.7 trillion
pounds built up during the pandemic with
many of us torn between splashing the
cash or keeping it for rising energy
bills
the new head of the armed forces admiral
sotoni rakin has told the times he is
concerned over russia's underwater
activity particularly around crucial
communication cables under the sea
the attorney general zwella braverman mp
has been accused of politically
motivating meddling after she said she
could refer the acquittal of four black
lives matter protesters who toppled a
statue of edward colston to the court of
appeal
the sun reports that singer and actress
denise van outen has broken up with her
fiance after he cheated on her
and the star leads on television's eamon
holmes hopes for curing his back pain
we're joined tonight by susie boniface
and freddie gray welcome to both of you
uh let's start with the telegraph and as
we mentioned in that run-through of the
the newspapers this is the story that
the government scientific advisors are
suggesting that a fourth jab will not be
necessary at least not for now susie
yes and it's good news in a way because
it does mean that the nhs can
concentrate on getting the third booster
jab out to people and of course in some
cases there will be force jabs for those
who are immunosuppressed and need more
than one injection of different doses as
we go through so um what they're saying
here is that actually you've got enough
antibodies from the from the first
booster the third jab um if you if you
have that that should protect you um
there are one or two other countries
which are thinking about forced jabs
israel has been trialling it and rolling
it out and says that there's a five-fold
increase in antibodies but experts seem
to be a bit divided as to whether or not
it's useful
what this does mean though is that the
nhs like i said can concentrate on on
the vaccines that we've got now and then
in the next year we're going to be
getting
very specific vaccines new ones that are
designed totally for the new variants
we've seen arise
and so they uh we may need to be
vaccinated again next year but that'll
be a whole fresh new vaccination but of
course by then we'll have whole fresh
new variants to worry about so this is a
bit of news in the sense that you know
as that one of the experts is saying
here we can't possibly vaccinate the
whole world every six months not that we
vaccinated the whole world yet anyway um
so this is a way of basically saying
that well at least we can concentrate on
what we're doing well and look forward
to trying to do things a bit better in
the future yeah seemingly good news um
for the moment the joint committee on
vaccination immunizations are saying
that a fourth jab would only provide
limited additional benefit against
severe disease at this present time
freddie
well i think it is good news and i think
there's also a little bit of nudge
uh going on in the there's a there's a
theory within government that if we uh
put the fourth booster off more people
will take the third booster there's a
certain amount of depression in people
thinking they're just going to have to
constantly take the fourth booster but
it is good news and as susie says uh you
know the last thing the nhs nhs needs
now is a
massive uh
another booster rollout drive so it's
good news and it also suggests that at
the moment and i don't want to sound
sort of um cocky here but at the moment
we're looking at possibly a good news
cycle on kobit i mean there does seem to
be a bit of a peaking happening after a
very alarming crisis in the build-up to
christmas
uh and i think people are starting to
feel people within government deciding
to feel a little bit more confident
about the next few weeks yes and
certainly susie the all the evidence
seems to be pointing to the fact that uh
omicron at least it is is certainly
milder that than delta
uh milder yes but unfortunately because
it's infected so many more people uh
those who work in the nhs aren't
particularly looking forward to the next
few weeks uh because they're saying
that's when uh what's already happened
and what's already uh the infections
that have been passed around over the
festive period is but that they've been
baked in and that's when it's really
going to hit we've already got uh dozens
of nhs trusts declaring major incidents
sharing resources and it looks likely
that the next few weeks are going to be
very sticky indeed if you happen to work
in a hospital where there are an awful
lot of staff vacancies which are making
it significantly worse
freddie take us to the times uh and this
story of warning about the the threat
from russia the admiral sir tony radican
the new defense chief has um some quite
serious concerns
well yes if you if you listen to uh the
sort of forum experts foreign policy
experts of the world there's been a sort
of drum beat
of concern about russia particularly
ukraine and now over kazakhstan uh in
recent weeks but i upset i do feel
sometimes a little bit skeptical about
these stories about hypersonic missiles
because you do feel they're a little bit
briefed out by people with sort of
intelligence interests
who are always quite keen to sound as
hostile as possible towards russia and
putin i'm not saying that
putin is not a dangerous menace uh to
the free world he is in many ways but i
i think when it comes to talk about
hypersonic missiles and things sometimes
these stories can get a little bit
overblown
susie the admiral's particularly
concerned about um crucial underwater
communication cables being tampered with
by by moscow and if that were to happen
he suggests that that would be
considered as an act of war
yep those are the undersea cables that
carry most of our internet and our data
all around the world a lot of them in
the atlantic where there's been more
russian activity and while the russian
navy is extremely ancient creaky and
rusty uh run by conscripts uh it is able
to actually intercept those cables uh
and cause severe disruption he's saying
that would be an act of war and what's
interesting here is that the line that
freddie mentioned in the second column
about tony radican saying we're going to
need to develop hypersonic missiles now
those are missiles that are so fast they
travel a mile a second they're so fast
that by the time they've blown you up
you still haven't seen them you know by
the time you've noticed them you've been
obliterated that's it you're gone
and there is no defense system in the
world that can protect anybody against a
hypersonic missile now they're being
developed by the us by russia by china
and he's saying here that we are going
to have to have our own what's
interesting about this is that we
started on a concept with the french
back in 2011 which was stepped up in
2016 for a joint anglo-french uh
hypersonic missile called perseus and in
2016 last september september 2021 we
were going to be signing a memorandum of
understanding with the french to uh to
push things forward so we could get that
hypersonic missile and protect ourselves
with it
unfortunately we then had a deal with
australia about submarines which meant
australia dropped the french submarines
and therefore france delayed signing
that memo of understanding and it looks
likely now that we wouldn't even get
perseus until the 2030s maybe even later
uh tony radican told parliament this
week we're gonna have to try and find
someone who wants to build that missile
with us now so we're in a situation
where we really really need
one of these whizzy new missiles
everybody else is getting one and we
could be in serious danger if we don't
but
we've upset the only person that we were
building it with so we're now going to
either find billions and billions and
billions of pounds to build our own or
try and piggyback on someone else's
design it's all a bit sticky really
freddie take us into the guardian and
this is the story of the attorney
general for england and wales announcing
that she could refer the acquittal of
the the constant four to the court of
appeal um and this has not been uh met
too kindly by some
well i think i mean there's been a lot
of concern uh
among in the conservative press and
among conservative mps
uh about this case uh i mean i think it
does set a dangerous precedent when you
say that um destruction of public
property uh is something that can be let
off
uh if uh
it's considered that
the cause is right
um and i think that
politicians are right to raise their
concerns about it and it's not
necessarily meddling with the judicial
system uh to say so as as
the guardian piece suggests
susie were your thoughts is it meddling
um
yes because the jury system it doesn't
set a precedent in criminal law okay so
if a jury decides to acquit someone
whether they're guilty or innocent of
what they've actually done if the jury
decides you haven't committed the crime
here that's worth us convicting you for
that's what our jury system is for it's
not up to politicians to question that
uh however if what sorella bravaman does
is to refer it to a higher court to look
at it again then that would actually set
a criminal precedent which would affect
future cases so it might backfire on her
spectacularly anybody who's concerned
about statues being made to go for a
swim
might want to ask themselves how they
felt about the statue of saddam hussein
coming down in baghdad and being hit by
people's shoes or statues of lenin and
marx coming down after the fall of the
berlin wall or indeed the removal of
swastikas after the allies liberated
europe we take down things that we don't
want to glorify anymore and no one ever
wanted to glorify edward coulston even
when they put the statue up nobody
wanted to do it so it seems fair enough
to me that you took a dunk
um it doesn't say what uh swella
braverman's um point of law is that
she's concerned about so that that's
that's that's quite interesting
it'd be quite interesting to see how how
that uh pans out
i'd like to chip in and say i'm
generally against taking down statues
even of people i find despicable
because
uh because i i just think it's bad bad
precedent you know if you don't like
something that's a public monument you
shouldn't take it down i mean you can
talk about saddam hussein but that's in
a war situation i think that's slightly
different
what what's your view on on statues that
that you find the the
people despicable what's your view on
them being placed perhaps
in a museum or somewhere else but not
being on on public display
is that an alternative well i mean i've
seen statues of lenin uh and i think
lenin was a fairly despicable figure in
many ways i've seen statue of stalin
erected in someone's private garden and
i think that's despicable but i wouldn't
tear it down
uh i just don't really believe in doing
that i think it's a silly thing to do
and particularly with public property
and this story about
people um
feeling free to book holidays now
because uh if they're double jabbed it
makes it a lot easier freddie
well yes i mean i would say slightly
watch out because uh the possibility
that booster jabs
uh will be required on a vaccination
pass in the future has not gone away
um but again i think like the first
story we discussed i think this is a
sign of good news i think this is a sign
of increasing optimism
uh about the crisis and again let's not
get complacent
uh but i think people are beginning to
feel that we can we can have a
we can have travel again in the future
uh and that's an encouraging sign but
but if we've learned anything it's it's
a movable situation isn't it uh nothing
stays still for very long
well it's been a terrible terrible um
time and i mean i hope for the travel
industry
uh finally we're through this because
i'm not sure it's gonna be able to cope
with another wave
of cancelled holidays and and refunds
and so yeah yeah uh susie a huge spike
in in bookings uh
is being reported um
jet 2 chief executive steve hippie
saying people are absolutely desperate
to get away
of course and if i was running a
business that had been severely
suffering in the last two years as soon
as i got some bookings that's what i'd
be saying too but uh this is the busiest
week of the year always for the travel
industry so this was always gonna be
time they should have had a bit of an
uptick anyway i'm sure the announcement
about uh easing travel rules has made it
easier but we also don't know quite when
these bookings are for of course one
assumes that a lot of it's going to be
over the summer when we can all be a bit
more experienced now about how the
pandemic's working out we can probably
all assume that the summer's going to be
better than the winter
so um you know that's not bad news there
is there is something a bit grim towards
the end in the copy there where sajid
javid apparently warn the cabinet that
if you keep off the travel restrictions
and you encourage all these holiday
makers that that massively increases the
risk of importing a lovely fresh new
variant to cause problems next winter so
uh love is optimistic as freddie and go
oh that's all marvellous we're over this
now um i think the possibility is that
the odds i did not say that i didn't say
we're over this but i mean i think i
think
i think the thing with variance right as
far as we can think with mutations as
far as we can tell as you will damned if
you do damned if you don't suppression
of the virus leads to mutation uh spread
of the virus leads to mutation so
uh i i think it's you know it's a very
perilous situation i'm not being um it
is overly tangling about that